this morning we have conflicting stories
of why the president summit with Kim
jong-un ended with no deal on nuclear
weapons mr. Trump says he walked away
because the North Korean leader wanted
complete relief from US sanctions North
Korean officials said in a rare news
conference that they only wanted some
sanctions lifted meanwhile Democratic
and Republican lawmakers are criticizing
the president for suggesting Kim was
unaware of the cruel treatment of
American prisoner otto warmbier Errol
Barnett is at the White House where
officials insist the president was right
to say no to a deal Erol good morning
good morning a senior State Department
official tells CBS News late last night
that North Korea wanted sanctions relief
on effectively every product except for
weapons and a senior government official
tells us that that would have meant
North Korea would have received billions
of dollars in sanctions relief without
any assurances on how or when it would
denuclearize I wanted to stop here to
share my gratitude on his way back to
Washington President Trump made a
refueling stop at this Air Force Base in
Alaska thanking US service members there
but he did not discuss his summit with
kim jeong-hoon
which was abruptly cut short how they
wanted these sanctions lifted in their
entirety and we couldn't do that earlier
the president said North Korea's offer
included dismantling its central nuclear
research and development facility in
exchange for complete sanctions relief
just hours later North Korea's foreign
minister ryeong Ho said his country
wanted only partial sanctions relief I
hope and pray that the talks continue
but if they break down
it's time to end their nuclear program
on Thursday top lawmakers on both sides
of the aisle said the president walking
away without a deal was better than
leaving with a bad one the president
treats everything like it's a real
estate deal just let me in the room I
can convince the other party to make a
deal former Vice President Joe Biden
actively considering a run for the White
House in 2020 said the president needs
to empower officials in his
administration to negotiate hard hard
hard consistent diplomacy the president
also suggested Kim jong-eun was not to
blame for the death of american student
otto warmbier who died after returning
from a North Korean prison I don't think
that the top leadership know about it
those comments drew bipartisan anger
here at home we know what happened to
Otto we know what this country has done
the attempt to sort of exonerate or
excuse Kim jong-un over the death of
this young man I thought was just best
more now president Trump said he doesn't
think what happened to otto warmbier was
in the best interest of Kim jong-un and
therefore he says he doesn't believe
chairman Kim knew what was happening to
that American prisoner while he was in
North Korea John Merrill thank you